Welcome back everyone it's Charlie.
Marvel just had their big shang chi movie
premiere Monday night in their allowing everyone
to post their early reaction.
So try to be as non-spoilery during this video
as possible.
If you're new to the channel, be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos I will do all the full
Easter egg videos post credit scene videos
everything after the movies officially released
in a couple weeks of you get a chance to see
the movie before that happens.
Please don't post spoilers on this video,
but overall I just seems like we have another
banger in the MCU tier list of movies as evidenced
by the fact that Marvel is allowing everyone
to post their reaction.
So early uses a really easy test for this
is when the movie studio releases a movie
in they know that it's bad.
They know the critics are gonna trash and
they won't let anybody talk about it to.
Like right before comes out so the fact the
marvel is like please everybody talk about
this movie is much as possible weeks and weeks
before it comes out is a really easy way to
say oh we know we have a banger on her hands.
The only exception to that rule was Avengers
infinity war and Avengers endgame.
They would let anybody that sought early talk
about it to.
Like right before came out.
But that was because of spoiler considerations
because it was such a big deal.
So if you really big fan of martial arts movies
and you really bummed out by what they did
was snake eyes because it was kind of a stinker
this past year the shang chi movie is here
to redeem your faith in Hollywood's ability
to make martial arts films just in general.
We have the marvel what if episodes that are
happening right now.
You can make the joke what if marvel what
if Hollywood made of martial arts movie.
But it was awesome Teemu Leo is great is the
shang chi character normally you expect marvel
to brand-new characters cameos in other peoples
big movies before they get their big solo movie
Like they did with the Black Panther character
in Captain America Civil War.
But I don't feel like that put him at a disadvantage
when you get to the shang chi movie.
At this point.
The way the fan base follows the moviemaking
process from start to finish we've known about
him and his character since comic con 2019
is been a hot minute.
Usually the only time they need to do those
big intro is like he's a character in then
do his solo movie is when they spring stuff
on you.
Like surprised and at this point the marvel
moviemaking system is a well oiled machine
is really all the marvel TV series with the
Disney plus stuff that they're trying to figure
out like even though the black widow movie
was kind of an extra thing the got tacked
into marvel phase 4 being more of a marvel
phase 1 phase 2 kind of movie like we should've
gotten it years and years ago and careful
for spoilers for the black widow post credit
scene at that a couple videos recently where
it seems like people are waiting.
Like 10 years to watch that movie, so I just
put a blanket spoiler warning for the black
widow post credits even though that movie
takes place a long time ago in the timeline
this marvel phase 4 Post credit scene with
Val revealing that yelena belova has been
working for her for a good long while after
the events of Avengers endgame and is giving
her a mission to go kill Hawkeye though is
a marvel phase 4 movie.
There's really only like a couple minutes
of that movie.
There technically marvel phase 4 pushing the
story forward.
So even though the entire black widow movie.
Just worked really well is a movie was a solid
film.
It just got released.
It is super awkward part of the marvel movies
timeline not even counting all the real-world
delays that happen.
Because the virus the difference with the
shang chi movie is that is truly marvel's
first completely new IP completely new group
of characters completely new marvel phase
4 movie for those you that and wanting something
fresh and new.
Like give me something new.
But give me something that feels like marvel.
Notice I said movie.
Because the what if series is also kind of
doing the same thing during completely new
completely weird stuff but it's a TV show
and is relying on old characters like even
though we got falcon and winter soldier.
Which is marvel phase 4 setting up Val who's
a huge deal now Wandavision the Loki series
with that big teaser ending in the Kang multiverse
war was like the next big thanos level threat
and marvel phase 4 all those projects or sort
of carryovers from avengers endgame in the
infinity saga movies like bridges between
what came before the pre-existing major characters
and what comes next.
So you think of them more like transition
projects in the really reductive way to describe
the shang chi movie is that it's like marvel
giving the Black Panther movie treatment to
another brand-new group of characters from
the iron man comics in the master of kung fu comics
Like here's something you've never seen before
in this corner of the marvel universe that
you've never seen before.
If you miss my trailer video yesterday the
movie is set in present day of the MCU after
the events of Avengers endgame.
If that wasn't clear from the trailers and
if not really familiar with the shang chi
character in his origins in the comics, yet
you started out in the comic book called master
of kung fu in the late 1970s during the big
pop-culture kung fu craze he was meant to
be marvel's version of Bruce Lee because Bruce
Lee at that time was blowing up in pop culture.
Just in general think about the way that Marvel
treated the Black Panther movie in those characters.
It wasn't overly concerned was shoehorning
in every avengers character you've ever seen
it only loosely acknowledged and reference
the other marvel movies Black Panther had
been in which was Captain America Civil War
and that was just for the sake of continuity.
There was only a small post credit scene with
winter soldier a.k.a. the white wolf the white
panther as falcon joke during falcon and winter
soldier was their mostly to pay off the captain
America Civil War post credit scene and indirectly
tease that something on the horizon was coming
in that was Avengers infinity war.
But nobody in the post credit scene specifically
mentions thanos or the infinity stones the
shang chi movie trees is characters in that
setting.
Like that lose connections and references
to other marvel movies to explain where it
fits in the timeline payoff Easter eggs for
the Mandarin the 10 rings they go back to
the original Iron Man movie.
Like part of the Movie Takes place in San
Francisco the Ant-Man Movies Also Take place
in San Francisco, which is that the Black
Panther movie shang chi is most of setting
up a so mythology the way that they set up
the history of Wakanda the panther tried the
history of the Black Panther and vibranium,
so just like that movie, shang chi feels like
something totally new and different really
cool in the MCU.
We all know he's going to crossover with the
avengers when they get to the next big avengers
movie, but they do enough world building in
a really cool way that they can make the entire
shang chi trilogy the way they typically do
trilogies for marvel movies just using 99%
brand-new characters you never seen for the
MCU new locations new mythology in the same
way that the Black Panther movie.
Just introduce you to a completely new idea
inside the MCU completely new area we get
to Black Panther tubeless even more.
That is called wakanda forever.
It's mainly gonna be another Wakanda movie.
Even though there odyssey introducing a bunch
of new characters.
The opposite of those ideas will be a movie
like Captain America Civil War where you have
every character from almost every franchise
in the MCU except for like Thor and hulk all
jammed into the same movie you probably heard
people going crazy about all the fight choreography
in the movie.
The way they film shang chi the camera language
also makes the movie feel very different from
other marvel movies, the visual styles much
for what you'd expect from the trying to blend
classic kung fu action movies with traditional
Western Hollywood blockbusters was an extended
clip of one of the bigger fight scenes in
the movie that I included in one of my trailer
videos yesterday, so I'll add a link for that
down in the description visited teaser for
the fight choreography they get way crazier
than that when you see the full fights in
the actual movie gets even better like the
bus fight scene is fantastic.
We've only got little pieces of it in the
trailer so far.
You may have seen that the fight choreographer
they used on the movie is the same one from
the matrix movies and he is bad ass.
So no surprise, the fights are all awesome.
So shang chi's style of fighting because is
based on kung fu feels very different from
the way the other marvel characters fight
you will get really excited to think about
what it'll be like when he's fighting with
the other avengers characters and big battles
in the future.
The way they dress the Mandarin the 10 rings
of it all in the MCU is very cool Tony Leung
was fantastic as he always is.
If you never seen his movies before he's done
some really badass kung fu movies like the
grandmaster is one of the more recent ones.
He's also done some amazing drama films every
single one of his won kar wai films are fantastic.
So I would encourage you to go check some
of those out if you haven't seen them.
They do answer most of your questions about
what he was doing this whole time in the MCU.
He is one of the biggest Iron Man villains
in the comics in marvel tried to use of Kevin
Feige said they wanted to use him as the villain
of the first Iron Man film before they pivoted
to obidiah stane they do pay all that often
clever ways while also still making everything
feel like it's totally new is sort of the
same idea behind the Black Panther movie with
his father King T'Chaka and his ancestors
the previous kings of Wakanda the previous
Black Panthers the way the Black Panther movie
explain how they were always around.
They were always involved in world affairs
on the DL traveling all over the world having adventures
Like there was a version of Black Panther
that was around during World War II when Captain
America was getting his origin story all those
characters were operating in super stealth
ways to hide the secret of Wakanda is a similar
situation with the Mandarin he's been around
superpowerful this whole time in the MCU influencing
things, but they explain why it is that he
wanted to stay off the radar is much as possible.
They kind of get into that a little bit with
the iron man three.
All hail the king one shot with Trevor getting
hauled in by the Mandarin for bringing so
much attention to him and the 10 rings the
rest of the castles fantastic Michelle Yeoh
is always amazing in everything that she does
the rest of the supporting cast around shang
chi like the core group that they put around
him was also great.
And a lot of people have thoughts about Awkwafina
for some reason.
Whatever your opinion of her is at least in
the movie her character in shang chi work
really well as a pairing just in terms of
plot and how this fits into the overall marvel
cinematic universe or marvel cinematic multiverse
because were after the Loki series.
Now with the big Kang multiverse war.
I know you have all kinds of questions about
Wong in the abomination the movie there really
cool in the movie, but I don't want to talk
too much about them before action comes out,
because are some spoilers for their characters.
We will have to wait a while to talk about
also big surprise you probably weren't expecting.
If you're a huge fan of the avatar the last
air Bender franchise the actor who's going
to be playing princes Ugo in the avatar the
last air Bender Netflix series is also in
the movie is a minor character's name is Dallas
Liu I know there's a lot of controversy over
what's happening with that particular avatar
the last air Bender series.
But he's totally fine as an actor the shang
chi movie doesn't have anything to do with
avatar the last air Bender other than it's
a westernized attempt at East Asian storytelling,
Shang Chi, thankfully is really solid homerun so you
don't need to worry about it falling into
the trap of the live action Avatar movie.
There are two Post credit scenes.
So make sure you stay after the credits no
spoilers.
But if you saw my last trailer video I posted
my theories and that wound up being right
on the money the trailer footage gives you
most of the clues you need to theory craft
what happens in the big credits and post credit
scenes.
If you have seen the movie.
Please do not post spoilers for those in the
video.
Although a totally separate video for those
post credit scenes in a couple weeks when
the movie comes out and we can talk about
what they mean how they set everything up
what's going to happen with the shang chi
character next in the MCU.
Because it is really exciting it does push
the story forward in really exciting way while
being vague enough to leave a lot of room
for speculation, so just in general.
If you been bummed out this past year.
There have been any huge marvel movies like
you normally expect and you feel like a black
widow movie didn't really feel new and fresh
enough shang chi is the antidote to that it's
only being released in theaters, it won't
be on Disney plus so do whatever you have
to do to go see it.
And once you do get a chance to see it.
If I haven't posted my full review video yet
are my Easter egg video just right your reactions
in the comments below.
Please do not post spoilers though my full
marvel what if episode 2 video will post next
that's for the Black Panther T'challa starlord
episode.
It is also going to be a banger.
So make sure you have alerts enabled for my
channel so you don't miss that.
Click here for my brand-new Spider-Man no
way home first look video and Easter eggs
and click here for my full marvel what if
episode one video.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you in the next video!